las elecciones en bolivia se acercan y
los seguidores del ex presidente evo
morales- vuelven a las calles para hacer
campaña por luís arse como candidato a
la presidencia ante unos adversarios
divididos en siete candidaturas
[Música]
el movimiento al socialismo se presenta
como la opción de izquierda por los
pobres y es la primera vez en 18 años
que lo hará sin evo morales- el partido
extraña al ex dirigente indígena asilado
en argentina pero apuesta por ar se que
va primero en los sondeos
[Música]
tenemos
el expresidente y candidato centrista
carlos meza segundo en las preferencias
ha apostado por una campaña virtual para
influir en las redes sociales pero sus
simpatizantes también están movilizados
creemos que hay un tribunal supremo
electoral totalmente independiente y
creemos que ahora que a través de
elecciones transparentes carlos mente
activas del presidente a la presidenta
conservadora y alinea las encuestas no
la favorecen y no pudo ser la figura de
unidad contra el movimiento al
socialismo aunque sus seguidores dicen
que la campaña va sobre ruedas el futuro
no se construye ni con tibios ni con
abusivos el futuro se construye con
coraje con el coraje que han tenido los
bolivianos para enfrentar las crisis que
hemos vivido la pandemia causa decenas
de muertos diarios y estragos en la
economía pero
la crisis no ha logrado que los
contrarios al movimiento al socialismo
supere sus propias ambiciones para
presentar una candidatura única